Most people think this fruit smells terrible.
It's been described using words like "rotting onions" or "raw sewage".
Not this guy, though.
If you're not that familiar with durian,...
...it has a spiky rind and the inside is a yellow, soft-colored creamy fruit.
It's native to Southeast Asia and because of its odor,...
...is actually banned from many public places.
Besides having a distinctive smell, durian also has a distinctive taste.
It's like a peanut caramel.
They have five flavors: sweet flavor, alcohol flavor, bitter flavor, flower flavor...
...and numb taste, total of five flavors.
And there are others who just can't get past the smell.
For Durian Seng, it is the perfect fruit.
Either you like it or you hate it.
Some people, they don't give it a chance to taste.
But you have to try it once in your lifetime.